so now let's draw a set of axes but
let's draw it a bit different to the way
we normally do it
here's how you normally do it see this
one that's what a set of axes
normally looks like right ah but see all
these numbers down here
all this area down here it's um
they're all negative numbers right like
negative one two three four
five and we're never going to use them
okay
it's irrelevant for this particular
graph so i'd like to draw a set of axes
but this time i just want you to draw
the top part
by the way draw it pretty tall draw it
pretty tall you'll see why in a second
the whole page um actually you could do
the whole page
you could do the whole page you're gonna
you could use it if you're gonna use the
whole page i'm gonna use the whole
height
okay now you guys have a tremendous
advantage which is that you have most
for for the most part you have grids
there okay even if you don't have grids
you've got lines which i don't have
so you can measure some things here okay
so here's what we're going to do
yes they are still the same axes y and
x that's right i'm just i'm just not
showing the bottom because i'm never
going to have something done
all right now let's try to plot this
thing okay
now i'm just going to need a little bit
more space over here
yep what if you needed y equals minus 2
okay if i had this graph
instead right think about what happened
when we did
this and then you compared it to this
then think about this
it's just the same and then you compared
it to this
there was a reflection right so if we
can get a picture of this
if you want to know what this looks like
just take that and
turn it over so just be all negative
that's right instead of all positive
everything will be negative let's give
this a go though okay you've um you've
punched this in numbers these numbers
six numbers okay so let's plot these
okay
let's make the highest point on your
graph the highest point
let's label that as eight okay so we all
have
a reasonably consistent thing because
that's as far as we need to go
okay now that's at x equals one to
three okay so however wide your thing is
you can go
one and then two and then three okay so
there's
three so now three comma a
that's a point that's on our graph
okay so three eight
something like that okay now as we go
backwards
right the next one is going to be two
comma four
right so here is two where will four be
remember we were halving right it'll be
exactly halfway
between eight and zero now you've all
got different
size graphs and that's okay just get
your ruler out and measure the line from
zero
to eight maybe yours is say 10
centimeters right so that means where
would you position
for five centimeters up right or
whatever for however high your graph is
mine looks like it'll be somewhere about
there
okay so four and now
okay and you can start to see what's
going on here right um
one two
okay now when we get to this value right
this is on the y axis right zero
comma one again that'll be halfway
okay because that's where it hits the
y-axis remember that's a special point
we call it the y
it starts with an eye intercept very
good
okay okay and you can keep on
filling in right you've got a half
you've got a quarter they're just going
to be
you know half that distance and you'll
have a half
here
and if you have it again you get a
quarter
and even though i haven't worked out
well i haven't written down what the
next one will be
it's going to be half again right
something like this
you can see now why it was so important
to have your graph really tall
mine is like oh how big is a how big is
a book let's see
mine is at least one two two and a half
like it's it's so much taller than yours
and down here you can still see they're
all very close together
yeah and it eventually hit the line okay
so
great question hold on let me just
repeat it and see if i understand it
right just to make sure everyone's on
the same page
nathan's asking well if i keep going if
i draw this further
and then plot more lines on where i
eventually hit
the x-axis okay now i guess the question
is
will the number here oh my whiteboard
market now if it's the whiteboard marker
well the whiteboard market it has
it has thickness right so eventually
just like with the cake
okay you cut and eventually where'd my
cake go it's just
a mess right but if i think about just
the numbers
right like you said you know one over
512
right or the uh let's see the biggest
power of two off the top of my head that
i know is 65
536 okay that's a really really small
number
but it's not zero and no matter how far
you go you will never get there
okay so now can we try to join this
thing up won't be easy
right because it's um it's meant to be
curved but can we connect it all up
yes give it a go let's try it do it with
pencil please do it with pencil
because it's not easy to do especially
the first time you've drawn such a graph
connect the dots but don't do them don't
do them as straight lines because as you
can see
if you sort of step back you can see
there's a curvature to it
right
okay how does yours look mine's
okay i could have done it better yeah
it's not easy is it
okay particularly like when you try to
join these and you're like you're like
oh i missed
or you know it's not easy um a couple of
quick questions
right or are you asking a question are
you stretching asking questions yeah
so i mean the line will just keep
getting flare inflatable
that's exactly right okay so let's keep
going on that when you say it keeps
going and going and going
just like we said look these values you
can halve forever that means this keeps
going
there should really be an arrow there it
doesn't stop it keeps going
right and in the same way you can keep
on doubling forever there's no upper
limit there's no ceiling
it just goes on however far you want to
draw
okay so you've got arrows on the ends
now remember how we said guess what and
this is what we just discussed no matter
how
many times you halve you'll never get to
zero
right so that means that there's always
this little gap
it's approaching zero this red line but
it never gets there
so we indicate that in a special way on
our graph i'll show you how
along the x-axis if you can in another
color
i want you to draw a dotted line it
looks like this
i've drawn a lot of dotted lines in my
life okay now this dotted line just like
when we started today we said oh look
linear graphs
we drew uh we drew this one and that one
and
that one and that one okay so linear
graphs like that dotted line we just
drew
they all have equations right what would
you guess the equation of that dotted
line
to b it's horizontal so is it an x
equals or a y equal
what it's actually a y equals i know
it's on the x axis but it's a y equals
because
all of the y values are the same now
what are all the y values one
how high is it it's going through the
origin
it's y equals zero okay so y equals zero
is a line that
this graph is approaching and
approaching and approaching forever and
ever but it never
gets there okay it never turns away but
it never
actually hits it okay and that's a super
special idea
it's so super special when super special
things turn up you give them names
right so this one is called it's a bit
weird to spell
it is called an asymptote
okay you might have heard the word what
we say is this graph
has an asymptote that asymptote is y
equals zero
or we say it is asymptotic
down here that's the um that's the
adjective
it sounds deadly it's a pretty fancy
looking word
okay so it's getting there getting there
getting there you've never
arrived so i said that actually of an
asymptote okay
it's a line that a graph approaches
but never actually reaches okay
and there's all different kinds of
asymptotes um you can have this one's
horizontal you can have vertical ones
you can have ones that are often an
angle that are called oblique
and there are all kinds of different
things so what is your getting closer
getting closer getting closer but never
arriving that's yeah that's right
that's an asymptote okay definition of
frustration are we there yet are we
there yet are we there yet the answer is
no
no never if it's an asymptote anyway
okay